today's one minute Monday is don't ask
for permission if you've got a great
idea that you want to try out something
that you know is gonna really help your
customers go and do it and don't ask for
their permission because usually what
happens is if it's something new but
something that hasn't been tried before
then they're scared and they're
skeptical and they're gonna say no a lot
of the times when you know that is
something that's gonna help them and I
recently made this mistake with one of
my clients I had this great new idea
that that I knew it helped them I knew
it'd help them accomplish their goals
but but they've never done it before and
so they're scared and they're worried
and they said you know maybe not now
maybe in a few months maybe we could
figure something out like ah I didn't
listen to my own rule because I know
what could have helped them and now if I
go and do it then I'm going against them
right they told me not to do it so I
can't go and do it now but if I didn't
ask for their permission the worst thing
that would happen is I'd have to beg for
their forgiveness and usually people are
pretty cool with that but you got an
idea you know it's gonna work for your
client don't ask for permission just go
and do it for them believe